so uh thanks a lot it's a pleasure to be
in a proxy of berkeley
um would have loved to be in berkeley um
so okay so so today is uh
i'm gonna talk about uh something which
uh i view
as essentially a third revolution
uh in uh in quantum and basically in the
world of quantum
okay so let's let's just start um
okay so so basically if if we
uh look at what happened over the past
uh god knows 30 years
uh well it was first there was the first
revolution 100 years ago
of the discovery of quantum but then the
second quantum revolution
is the the discovery of quantum
algorithms that's that's basically
um uh the revolution in which
uh computer scientists told uh quantum
people
look uh there's something here that's
interesting
and uh we may be able to use uh
quantum systems for our advantage um ten
years later
came uh the third quantum revolution
which base in which basically
physicists um realized that uh that
maybe they can learn something from from
those
quantum computation ideas not just uh
in terms of what they can do in terms of
uh building computers
but also in terms of uh of understanding
something about physics and
and looking at physics from through the
computational lens
and that gave birth to the idea of
quantum hamiltonian complexity to the
field of quantum hematology
and essentially made physicists
look at ground states and and i think i
think it was really
uh responsible for the penetration of
computational ideas into the the way
physicists think of
of their physical systems i want to
argue
that in the last 10 years there has been
another revolution um which is led
mainly by
experimentalists and uh while the
previous two revolutions were
were led mainly by theoreticians and and
and physicists were of course
participating but
it was more coming from the theory
community
here in the past 10 years there has been
a true revolution
coming from the experimental community
in which they actually borrow
algorithmic ideas quantum algorithmic
ideas
and completely change the way they think
about experiments
some of those ideas also come from from
the theory
side but uh it's mainly coming from
we see sporadic um new ideas of
computational ingredients like
entanglement
and and air correction and and uh
small quantum algorithmic steps etc
getting into experiments and i want to
argue first of all that this is a
revolution
and that there is theory missing here
meaning that
uh we are behind there is a uh
there are a lot there is lots of
interesting um
questions that uh that theoretical
questions
that uh uh that are very interesting and
there's of course
a lot of interesting experimental
questions here
there's actually possibilities of using
those ideas to gain
exponential advantages in certain
quantum
measurement tasks and and quantum
experimental tasks
okay so so what do i mean by the way
feel free to ask questions
as many questions as you want i i love
questions
okay so um uh this is a standard
experiment there's nothing
uh quantum computing about it it's an
x-ray diffraction experiment one wants
to study the structure of a crystal
and there is a crystal uh sample here do
you see my mouse no
right um
okay yes we do you do okay
um so there's a crystal sample here
and uh photons x-ray photons uh
scattering off it
hitting a camera and uh the the camera
is
augmented with some computer which
allows some post-processing of
the locations of where the photon hit
and that allows us to deduce the crystal
the structure of the crystal sound
okay so that's sort of an experiment a
simple experiment or a
sim it's not simple but it's simple in
the sense that it doesn't include any
quantum computing elements
okay i wanna i wanna uh progress to some
examples which in which
there are quantum computing elements uh
augment
in inside implemented in the in the
experiment um
and um and these are sort of
there's a large va variety of them and
if you're familiar with them
uh maybe a good question to to think
about is
how all these experi how all these
different types of experiments can be
put in one model together
um okay so so the first type of
experiments comes from
sensing and metrology example one
is how is the noon states noon states
uh are those states that look like uh
noon
uh n photons in one path and zero
photons in another
in some beam splitter and uh
entangle coherently superimposed with uh
zero photons in the other in the first
path and end photons in another
and it turns out that uh going from one
to n
that allows uh one to increase the
precision
of measuring um some phase that is
induced by the beam splitter
um whereas so if if there is if
one doesn't use this entangled state and
just in
sends a superposition of a single photon
and repeats it many times that means
that one needs to
to repeat the experiment uh two times to
get only one over square root of t
improvement in the precision that's the
standard quantum limit
but if one does this type of an
experiment
then that allows to get to the
heisenberg limit
behavior which is a quadratic
improvement using entangled states
highly entangled states or
these entangled states okay so that uses
the ingredient of entanglement
another example is to augment
with coming from a different direction
is to augment
um the uh our sample
that we want to say um measure with
very good precision um some kind of uh
uh of uh frequency um that is a
parameter of the hamiltonian
so um if we just do it uh uh
very very uh straightforwardly then um
we will have to wait until the
oscillations uh
uh there are enough oscillations and
eventually we'll get to the standard
quantum limit again
and and the point is that
during that time the oscillations decay
because of noise
and and that means that the precision
is not enough and that this is the
reason why we'll get the to the standard
quantum limit
if you it turns out that if you augment
the system by
uh by a very small error correcting idea
meaning error correcting small primitive
uh
say uh one or two qubits that are
uh highly very stable um and you use
them somehow
in a very rudimentary way to perform air
correction that allows the
uh the signal to be prolonged and the
and and one reaches the heisenberg limit
in certain cases um so so quantum era
correction can also be used in very
rudimentary ways
to um to avoid the the decay of the of
the signal
and therefore gain enough statistics to
to achieve the heisenberg limit
okay so that's these are examples from
sensing and from metrology
[Music]
here is a different example which comes
from from the area of black holes
the famous hayden preschool paper in
which one
one can this is an experiment i won't go
into the details of it but of course
it's a good duncan experiment
that basically tests uh the quest
questions related to the information
paradox um
by by using entanglement of
a large number of qubits emitted from
from the black hole and essentially
decoding
the these qubits after collecting them
and that requires a quantum
memory and also some kind of a quantum
computer
um so this is a different experiment
that needs a quantum computer
if you want to implement it okay so
that's another type of experiment
and here's another type of experiment um
that's an experiment that
that is its goal is uh is to verify the
the correctness of a certain evolution
of a quantum circuit
uh so that comes from a verification of
quantum circuits and uh
and uh it it involves another ingredient
which which was not exactly involved
before
and this is the ingredient of
interaction the ingredient of
interaction coming from
from theoretical computer science allows
a very a weak verifier to interact with
uh with a quantum computer
in the clever way in adaptive way um
[Music]
one one scheme uses an error correcting
code but it's not
essential the point is that we need
interaction and we need randomness
in order to actually uh be able to to
uh to test the the correct evolution of
the quantum computer
and so the ingredient here is
interaction and adaptivity
okay um maybe i will spend a little more
time on the fifth and last example
and that's the uh that's an example that
uh
that provides that uses quantum
computers to provide an exponentially
more precise
uh energy measurement measurement of the
of an energy of an eigenstate of
of a hamiltonian of a certain
hamiltonian so
okay so this comes from a paper by uh
uh by my student jose and myself
um and uh and it goes as follows so
yossi came with
the following idea um shaw's algorithm
is
is the task of sure's algorithm is to
factor a number n
described by n log uh by log n bits um
in in time which is polynomial in small
n and this is equivalent to finding the
order of
of uh of some number y which is co prime
to n
the order is the minimal r which uh
which satisfies y to the r equals one
modulo in
and we want to do that in polynomial
time polynomial in small m
and as we all know schwarz algorithm
allows to do that
um yossi's idea was
isn't that essentially equivalent
to uh to being able so there's an
exponential speed up here
um isn't that essentially equivalent to
being able to perform
energy and energy management measurement
exponentially fast
so how is that um
[Music]
so shawn's algorithm basically uh
uh takes the this unitary
which takes any x uh some binary
representation of a number between one
and nsa and multiplies it
by by this y here that we want to find
the order of
multiplies y by x modulo n
now shaw's algorithm
uh basically creates a superposition
over all those
uh uh over all those elements with
u to the t for t varying from from 0 to
n so big n is exponential and small n
so the whole point of shore's algorithm
is that one can actually raise
u to a power which is exponential very
efficiently
now we can actually look at that as if
we have a hamiltonian
h which is this unitary u plus u dagger
and look at e to the i h t
where t is very large and it turns out
that
by the same idea that one can actually
take you to an exponential
power this is very special the fact that
we can take you to an exponential power
um if we don't have a structure we need
to actually multiply u
so so e to the i h t
is something that we can actually do
here um
efficiently and um and this is something
that can be applied by a quantum
computer
because of the special structure of u in
time which is
uh which is polynomial in n
um for ts which are exponential in n
and so one can view this as the ability
to fast forward the hamiltonian to take
a quantum computer
and simulate e to the iht
for a certain amount of time t but the
simulation on the quantum computer takes
only
a logarithmic time in t or polylog
and it turns out that this is this
remarkable ability
allows us to perform an energy
measurement for an eigenstate of
of uh of h
exponentially with with exponential
precision very efficiently so how is how
does this go
well you if you have if you're given
this uh
initial state psi um and you add uh
and you add this state here 0 plus 1 and
conditioned in 1 you apply e to the iht
then you have since psi is an eigenstate
and h here becomes an eigenvalue you
have
this qubit in a state which has
information about the eigenvalue of the
hamiltonian
and if you can prepare polynomially many
uh qubits like that with t which
can go up to exponential you can this is
very well known
you can actually derive um
exponential precision on over the for
the energy
and um and it is and and what we prove
there is that fast forwarding this
ability to apply e to the iht in
in in very efficiently in time which is
much much shorter than the actual time
by a quantum computer um this is the
same
as the ability to to to measure
the energy exponentially with
exponential precision
in time meaning in computational time
which only grows polynomially with with
small n
and so this is a violation of of the
of the so-called time energy uncertainty
principle
it's an exponential violation of this
because delta e
the precision here is exponentially
small and delta t is just polynomial
so okay so so these are
sort of some examples where
surprising or or interesting advantages
can be actually achieved
using uh ideas or methods coming for
quantum computation
and there it seems like a very
um a very uh
very i mean the variety of these of
these things is quite fast
and and one can actually ask well what
it what puts everything here in in some
common framework uh why am i talking
about them together and
and what what marie can i ask you a
question
you're oh hi jeff hi um
so this is their special this thing that
you just described is for special kinds
of unitaries right that you can do this
for
can you characterize what those are if i
got that right maybe i maybe i didn't
get that right
um
in fact you can do it for any for any
tea
um but let me not get into this uh
i mean even if you don't have you can do
it even for specialties and that's
enough
but let me not get into this because um
this is a detail
um okay so
so one can look at all at those examples
and
and ask well then why do i put them
together
and and if all of those are all of those
are related to some physical experiments
we're trying to measure something
so do you mind if i ask you a quick
question about previous slide
yes so this this sounds remarkable but
at the same time i'm i've been a little
bit wondering whether
this is a fair fair argument because
here you're assuming you can prepare
psi which is an eigen state
of the hamiltonian whose parameter you
want to estimate of
however the fact that you can prepare
the exact eigen this has to be exact
eigenstate it cannot be unapproximate
because otherwise your
um your energy resolution if it's an
it's a linear combination of multiple
energy eigenstates
you won't be able to resolve this energy
energy because they are
insulated uh the yeah that you can
prepare the state
within the energy resolution better than
or something means you already solved
the problem you already know the value
in some sense right so you know
so so there are two things i i should
have made more clear first of all
um the size that my input to the problem
uh i'm not preparing it and then
measuring it but i'm i'm assuming that
somebody
prepared for me psi or i have some some
state
in a physical system and i just want to
estimate its energy
now this is a very good point and indeed
um physicists that that here
the ability about the ability to measure
uh the energy with
exponential precision or to measure
something with exponential precision
um raise their eyebrows because
because uh any we cannot hope to prepare
or to have a state with exponential
precision
but this exponential precision there are
two different types of exponential
precision even if the state itself
is say contaminated a little bit by
another state which has
a slightly a different
eigenvalue so you'll have the
superposition
the effect on the algorithm is that
you'll have
the correct answer with very good
probability with exponentially good
probability
but and you'll have another answer
with uh with ex with another ex
was just a small error probability it
doesn't affect the precision
it just affects the probability that you
get the correct answer but the correct
answer will be given with exponential
precision
so you will get the correct answer with
some
with some very good probability and the
precision of the answer
is to within exponential error
can i get a quick question yeah love it
uh so so how different is it from phase
estimation i mean
the test seems exactly like phase
estimation but but you seem to realize
that
you should have said phase estimation
it's phase estimation there's nothing
there's no technically there's nothing
okay
you found something no no no no this is
this is not
just um a point of view on phase
estimation which
allows this of course of course yeah
sure
i should have said the word fine all
fine
but the point here is that uh is this
is this ability to do fast forwarding
that implies this exponential relation
for every hamiltonian
okay so so that works for for other
hamiltonians as well but
this is basically essentially um
it's it's a mapping of phase estimation
to the notion of uh
of energy measurements it need not
actually
algorithm to the notion of energy
measurements
it need not actually involve phase
estimation i think their main point is
that
when you have structure to the
hamiltonian like in this case you can do
modular multiplication
modular exponentiation then you can fast
forward so for example the harmonic
oscillator for which we have the basis
functions
you could also fast forward and get the
energy eigenstates just as easily
right so yeah so for example every
commuting local hamiltonian can also
work this that's right right i think
it's a beautiful interpretation
so okay so so now um we can look at all
these experiments
uh and all these suggestions for
experiments or experiments
and we can ask um well then what is a
physical experiment
if all those are experiments what what
do we how do we characterize a physical
experiment how do we model it
so how to model the most general quantum
experiment
in a way which is useful for us so we
want a model
that will enable us to study the
measurement processes and
and compare the resources and understand
how
precise they can be can they can be with
that those amounts of resources
um and we want that to not depend too
strongly on the physical implementation
just like
when we ask about the complexity of a
quantum algorithm we don't want that to
depend too strongly
on the implementation we want the
separation so we want to think of of
measurements as protocols
with with computation complexity
associated with them and we want to
study those
experimental protocols from a
computational point of view
so we want to sort of walk in this field
with with the help of
of uh an experimental version of the
extended church touring the quantum
church during thesis
um by the way i'm not sure i
i see here only experts in front on my
screen but
in if i say something that's not uh
that's not
understood please do ask questions uh my
screen only shows me
just a few friends okay so um
so we're looking for such a model and i
want to basically start by
by uh trying by by writing up a first
attempt
to to come up with a model a general
model for a quantum experiment
so what would that model be what what is
a quantum experiment
um in its most generality so i
i think that the most general
thing that one can say is first of all
we are looking for some kind
of a protocol that will allow us to
compute a function
given access to some physical system
we want to be able to to take this uh
this
uh physical system and uh
so this is the physical system here and
we want to map
it to to some number or to maybe a
probability distribution over some
numbers
okay so maybe
some string or maybe some probability
distribution
over such strings um and this is a
physical
thing okay so this is physics this this
is a physical system
um and maybe the first attempt
to to write down such a model would be
something like that we would be
so we i showed you an example in which
the system is in the
the protocol is interactive so um and we
know that we
don't understand the physical system so
maybe we should treat it as a black box
so maybe the first attempt would be
something like there there are
that can be used and this is time
and we query here um
our black box physical system and then
we maybe perform some quantum
computation and then we query it again
and and so on so forth so forth and then
the output will be the output of this
function
we measure and that's the output so it's
sort of a black box model
um i wish i could do raise of hands
if you think this is a good model
um but i want to argue this is not a
good enough model
um and the reason i want to say this is
not a good enough model is
let's look at our first example of an
experiment um
by the way this is uh um together with
cutler jordan kotler and sharing
we looked at this question and and uh
and this is the model that we came up
with we call it
quamps quantum algorithmic measurements
so let's look again at this at this
example so we have this crystal sample
we have x-ray photons we have the camera
one very important ingredient here is
that
indeed the experiment computes some
function from the physical system to
to some classical output but we're not
given full access to the input the input
being the the physical system
we're not given full access of course
we're not given a full description of it
um but we're not even given full access
to it meaning we can't actually interact
with all its degrees of freedom some
degrees of freedom are hidden
the degrees of freedom that we those who
operate the camera and the computer et
cetera can interact with are only the
photons
so basically there's not just uh
two things here the space the physical
space and the the workspace of in the
experimental
and the experimental lab but also
another
uh hilbert space which is hidden that
contains all the hidden degrees of
freedom
and there's a very important ingredient
which is the interaction
with with this hidden set of degrees of
freedom
is done via the photons in this case
but via some message
between the degrees of freedom and the
workspace
and so this brings us to the following
model it's it's a simple
combination we want it to be simple well
i'll show it in a second but let me
first say that we have
we will have three subspaces three
subsystems
um the workspace that we have for
control over
um the nature space
which on which we don't have any control
over these are the hidden degrees of
freedom
and the the photons which allow us to
interact with nature
and you should think of nature as
something that remembers
that the um everything that needs to be
remembered about about the physical
about the physical system what is its uh
how does it behave uh the state that
evolves
between different uh times of
interaction with with
uh the workspace or whatever um
okay so we have these three spaces
subsystems
and and the definition of of quantum
algorithmic measurements will be as
follows
um it's a hybrid of quantum interactive
protocols and those black box algorithms
that we started from
um so here here we have these three
registers nature lab and workspace
and we basically have um
an interactive protocol meaning a
quantum circuit
some something that that has to do with
the quantum system
it's a super operator we'll denote it by
epsilon nl
another quantum circuit epsilon l etc
[Music]
and and the physical system will be
described by
by two things these are this is my input
i don't i have access to it
only in a limited way through the lab
register but the physical system is
described by two things
one is the state the original the
initial state row n
and the other is some super operator
epsilon n l
and this is all that is this is the
entire description of the physical
system
and this row n allows for for
remembering
the state and and whatever you need to
whenever whatever the phys
the physics needs to remember about
itself
and the workspace has both
interactions with this uh with this
nature
and it calls the this uh
lab oracle super operator uh as a black
box
now okay so this is a familiar thing
uh that combines these two notions a
hybrid of of interactive protocols and
black box algorithms
these two familiar notions and i want to
just
uh say that they're two so sorry i'm a
little confused about
what is what here so your workspace is
is uh
who's the workspace and what what's the
can you can you say the role of these
three again which which is which in the
sure um so this is nature
nature meaning things outside of your
lab or
outside of your actual apparatus or is
it the environment
um nature you should think of as the
crystal
so it's a physical um
system that that contains but it but it
some of its degrees of freedom of the
physical system are accessible
and some are not nature are all those
that are not
okay so is it the environment of your in
in
so if you if you if you had some
apparatus in your in your lab is it the
environment
is it no i don't think of this as the
environment so i think the crystal
example is a good example um
i want to actually understand the
structure of the crystal
and so the crystal degrees of freedom
are n
[Music]
okay so this is actually what's
describing for me the physics that i
want to understand
but it's hidden for me and
l is my way of interacting with it so l
the lab is basically the
this in in my example these are the
photons
okay and w corresponds to the camera
and to the uh computer and to everything
that i have in my lab
that i have full control over
so dude i'm a little confused about
something which is
so what sort of description do you have
on
n do you know how big it is anything of
this nature nothing
no i don't have any any control over it
i'm viewing
i'll i'll define it in a moment more
precisely
but basically let me just show you and
then i'll go back to this slide okay
um ah it's not written i meant to write
it
okay so i'll write it here
so basically there are three ingredients
in the model
the first is is what we call the lab
oracle the lab article
is basically what describes the physical
system that we want
to study and the lab oracle is just
a pair of two things
so labor call
is a pair of two things it's row n
the input state oops and epsilon
nl and this is a super operator
this is a state and i don't know it
both i don't know the laboratory i may
have a guess for example i may have an
assumption that the lab oracle
that i can interact with belongs to some
set i have may have a promise like that
but
other than that i don't know i don't
know what it is
and what i want to do is i want to
compute a function of this lab oracle
maybe the question i was confused about
is you so you are
sort of assuming that this nature
follows some
follows quantum mechanics that that much
you have to assume
otherwise yes yes yes i'm not yeah i'm
not i'm not
playing here the game of not believing
quantum mechanics or anything
okay uh i'm playing here a game i mean i
could
par you could embed you could implement
you could present in this
scheme an experiment
that tests for example whether
whether a system follows a quantum
circuit description
but but the description of tensor
products
of hilbert spaces that i believe this is
yeah okay um but are you actually
assumed that nature follows quantum
mechanics or only the way you copy to
nature
follows quantum mechanics because i i
don't see anything specific quantum
mechanical and
i guess it could be as complicated as
you want right the whole end part i mean
there's no notion of locality for
instance right so there's no
no reason to to update the tensor
product structure really i guess
unless you put constraints on how the e
acts on the on the
answers it's possible that one can
actually release
the assumptions on quantum mechanics
here
on in the hidden degrees of freedom here
we are assuming i mean we're saying
there's one
um so i haven't actually thought about
what happens in this way we're actually
assuming that
that um physics is described
um by quantum mechanics
um to some to the extent
that uh it's described by hilbert spaces
and the description is quantum mechanics
mechanical and we just want to basically
extend
the quantum algorithmic picture into
quantum experimental protocols within
quantum mechanics
so for instance you could be radical and
completely freezer where you couple to
the environment if you make it just as
big as you want and just
use the environment row and to program
the ear right
i i i suggest i i mean i think this is a
very interesting question
this we should discuss this in the
discussion yes okay
okay but for now let's assume quantum
mechanics i'm just uh i'm basically
thinking of this as if uh um
it's an extension of the question what
kind of algorithms are there
on quantum computers now i'm asking what
kind of
experimental protocols are there in the
world in which
uh everything is described by by quantum
evolution
okay so what we're claiming
um is that this model seems to be
universal
i'll describe this in a moment but but
there are three ingredients to this
model first of all this is the lab
oracle
the initial state and the super operator
then there is the qua the sorry then
there is the task
what's the task let's move to the next
page so the lab oracle here
um is is this uh ro
n epsilon n
l this pair
okay now the task well basically
task is sort of the problem that the
experimentalist
faces okay so the experimentalists
wants for example to describe the
structure of the crystal
in in some classical way which is
i don't know which is comprehensible so
what she wants is she wants to she wants
to compute a function
from the set of lab oracles
that are possible um so she's assuming
something about the crystal or something
i don't know that it's a
that is described by a local hamiltonian
or there's some description there's some
assumptions
um plus she she might also be getting
um some description of what kind of
experiments she's going she wants to
to perform um for example
at what temperature she wants to to
estimate
something about the crystal or or things
like that so so these
these um uh there's an extra parameter
classical parameter that could be given
which could be specification of the
experiment
so the function takes this extra
parameter
and the set of lab oracles say i don't
know let's put here
n and outputs some
classical output
now this classical output is extremely
general
okay it could be for example the output
of machine learning
a quantum machine learning algorithm
that looks at
at the physical system and outputs a
classical
description of a quantum circuit that
learned how to
predict the the the behavior of that
quantum system
it's it's very very general okay and in
fact
um in fact uh it's not exactly the right
thing to do to put here deterministic
function
function the right thing to do given the
fact that the lab oracle could come from
a continuous set is to uh
to to be able to output some probability
distribution
for any for every lab oracle
it can output a probability distribution
oh i'll just
say very quickly why it's not a very
important point but
um but why because if the for example
think of a tomography
situation where the lab oracle could be
something that generates a state
and you want to understand what's the
state you want to do tomography to
within some approximation
now for this to make sense you cannot
request that uh
on a continuous space um
there is a function that's defined and
and and you want a protocol that that
computes this function correctly uh to
within a good probability for every
point because there will be points in
which
extremely they're extremely close but
the function will be defined differently
on
on two point two very close points
arbitrarily close
so if you want to to make uh functions
which make sense from a smooth
from from a smooth set you want this to
be
actually probability distribution but
never mind think of of deterministic for
now
okay so um so that's the task
and the specification of the task is not
only the function
but it also the experimentalist is
facing also the problem that
she has only uh she has some limitations
in her lab for example that the
that the gates that she has are are
limited or that there is limited
interaction between the workspace and
the lab
register etc so there is also
um some kind of a set of gates that is
allowed
with with the restrictions on that set
of gates for example maybe that on w
she's only allowed to apply classical
gates or something like that
okay so so so the rate uh i didn't
completely follow what you said could
you say it a little faster so i can
sure okay so um but which one did didn't
you not follow
the task the entire task yes yes so what
okay so the last part is fine right yes
yeah the lab oracle is fine
uh i think so okay so there is a
physical system that's the lab oracle
and the task is basically the task of is
is the problem that the experimentalist
faces she wants for example
to to have an ex to design an experiment
that um will take her sample
her physical sample and will output some
classical property of it
and she has some specifications of what
she can do in the lab
that's g that's a set of gates she can
implement
the task is her specification of the
problem
was that fast enough um
well i i guess um and and
is is the specification in terms of
nature
so you know that's what what's puzzling
me uh
so does it say what function of nature
you want to compute
in which case it's a pretty hard thing
to say
so how do you specify all that
um i'll give an example in a moment but
for example
you can say that that you know that you
have
two sample that your sample is taken out
of two possibilities
and you just want to know which one it
is
for example you have a system which is
either
two local or three local and you just
want to know if it's if it's that or
that
okay um so so you can
assume something about the lab oracles
that they come from a subset
say local hamiltonians and you want to
find out their locality
for example so you don't have to
actually
okay is that good
what's the quan the quorum is actually
the the solution the experimental
protocol that the experimentalist
actually runs in her lab meaning the
exact
uh specification of how to implement the
how to put the beam splitters here and
the the magnetic
fields there etc but we are viewing it
as a quantum circuit
so we just describe this quantum circuit
meaning these quantum circuits in the
middle plus
the application of a query so here we
don't know epsilon at all but we
but the experiment just says okay at
this point in time we
apply epsilon nl and she can make a
query
to that epsilon n that's that's the
quant
specification of this protocol
is that clear
yeah okay
okay so that's uh so this is the model
how are we doing on time we're very very
uh
slow here okay so so this is uh
um this is a qualm and uh if you
run through our examples which i will
not do
you will see that uh so i i did i did
actually say a little bit about
how you model the xy the x-ray
diffraction
uh where here this is the crystal this
is these are the photons and this is the
workspace
but for example the measurement with a
quantum correcting code
um well it's just exactly this um
the the sample um
the sample is here and the lab here is
just
extra qubit or two which can
which can be much more robust and you
control it
and the quantum circuit is essentially
this rudimentary quantum era correction
that you apply all the time
and at the end you measure so okay so
verification is more complicated to
explain
and i won't go into that and there were
other experiments but but it's a very
good exercise
to try to think about any experiment
that you you want and try to put it here
and i think that you will see that there
is no way around
so for example in verification maybe i
will say one word about it in
verification
you want to test that the certain um
[Music]
system is actually behaving like like a
quantum computer
what's a quantum computer it's a hybrid
quantum classical hybrid which takes
um descriptions of quantum gates
classical descriptions and applies it
and you want to test that it does things
correctly so
um you're you cannot actually go into
exactly what it does this is the hidden
uh degrees of freedom
but you can give it various instructions
and test it
so this is you have this is i was trying
to convince you why you need hidden
degrees of freedom
in the model you cannot just apply black
box
okay so let me very quickly say just a
little bit about
what's uh what are some results and i
want to move to the discussion which i i
want really want to hear
what people have to say um okay so so
just
naturally quan complexity is measured by
number of gates
and by the oracle calls so it's really
trying to
to quantify what is the complexity of an
experiment
and we believe as i said that this is
universal model for for quantum
experiments
and one can ask now how much do do the
the new computational ingredients of
that quantum computation brings along
how how how much can it give to to
quantum experimentalists
maybe we can design new quantum
experiments using
quantum algorithms here and using
adaptiveness and using various
things and there are sort of many many
different questions to ask here
trying to separate the types of
experiments and what kind of experiments
uh actually um can buy you
advantage so you can ask whether
coherence between
uh the workspace and the labs the lab
register
um buys you anything or maybe maybe the
type the the type of experiments that
are
done usually in the lab in which you
just apply the
apply the let the system just evolve and
then measure it and then
collect information and just do
classical post-processing
maybe that is good enough how does
adaptivity get into the picture
is this is this useful at all or not
um how do things behave in terms of the
number of queries maybe you don't need
too many queries
and how complex do we need to make those
quantum states
that we prepare here and the quantum
operations or maybe
maybe very simple ones are sufficient
okay so i want to tell you uh one one
result that that we have and and also
about some other results that other
that are very related um
and and end by that and and basically
in in our paper we concentrated on on
the following question we wanted to
really ask
how much does coherence in time and in
space
bias and what do i mean by coherence in
time and in space
i mean let me let me jump because we are
we're in lack of time
um
[Music]
so we wanted to study what's the
difference between this coherent model
that i told you about and the incoherent
qualm which essentially can describe
most experiments done today
in which between every application
of the physical super operator there is
some
complete measurement being applied
and the interaction between the
workspace and the these
this physical system is classical
um but other than that you can prepare
complicated states and you can apply
complicated measurements etc and we
wanted to know
does it buy us a lot or not the
coherence
and it turns out that it does that for
there are two we found two tasks which
are physically motivated
um or at least there are toy examples
toy versions of physically motivated
tasks
in which there's exponential advantage
to to coherent uh
um to coherent qualms
we need coherence both in space and in
time
sorry can you clarify i i don't know
what maybe it's a dumb question but i
don't know what coherence
in space or time means um
here so let me i try to define
incoherent
by basically saying that the interaction
between w and l
is by locc it's classical interaction
and that there is complete measurement
between every two applications of the
lab oracle
super operator so so
this complete measurement prevent
prevents coherence in time
and the fact that we require loc here
prevents coherence in space
so this is incoherent and anything else
is coherent
okay even though it might be partially
coherent or something like that yeah
we just okay yeah yeah we want to
separate incoherent from
anything that's not incoherent that uses
coherence to some extent
great okay and and what we showed is
that
for for two problems
uh there is an exponential advantage the
first problem
is the following we want to distinguish
between the following lab
two lab oracles one is the system picks
a fixed unitary high randomly
and commits to it forever
here is a picture uh picturesque way of
looking at the lab oracle description
the other lab oracle is it picks a new
unitary every time
and clearly if you can apply a swap test
you just
apply twice this unitary and if it's the
same
you can test that it's the same
so a swap test would do by two
applications
and the question is can you do it
incoherently
the other question the other problem is
uh so so the first problem has to do
with
can be associated with a question of
checking whether a hamiltonian is is
uh periodic or is time independent or
not
the other problem is maybe more
physically motivated is checking the
symmetry
of of different systems whether
their uh evolution is unitary or
orthogonal or
or coming from a symplectic form
and and this too turns out that one can
actually
come up with some some not too
complicated swap
test thing that that basically
distinguishes between these three
symmetries
what we managed to do is we managed to
and this is a complicated proof
which i won't say anything about um
we managed to actually prove a lower
bound um
for the case of incoherence it used it
uses weingarten functions
if you know what that is and some and
and and the
the thing that makes it hard is the
adaptivity the lower bound works also
for adaptive case
and that makes the integrals uh you need
to do some
some something to to make it work
um okay so um
so what we get is that uh um
efficient coherent qualms versus inquiry
and qualms that need exponentially many
queries
and so there's an exponential advantage
for coherent over incoherent
experiments
now
there one one can wonder whether whether
well
aren't there other don't we already know
that from from quantum algorithms
that coherence help helps um
for example simon's algorithm requires
coherence isn't that
sort of a demonstration of such an
advantage at least maybe not
experimentally
or maybe not of interest to
experimentalists but
at least something well no because
simon's advantage actually in this model
of incoherence
it's actually incoherent because you can
call your you can prepare
a superposition which is a product state
and you apply the oracle and then you
measure in the hadamard basis
and that's it that's it you don't need
any coherence
so it lies in the incoherent model it
even
lies lower in the hierarchy it's just
local local
um is it clear that these two different
mechanisms of getting a quantum
advantage are distinct
i mean there's also some mechanism
behind behind simon's algorithm right so
is it clear that it's really a distinct
mechanism or is it just that
you'll have to define what do you mean
by mechanism
i want to distinguish it in in
let me say one more sentence and then
maybe we'll it will
say something it will answer um
interestingly after we
we've just found that there are examples
um there are known examples that were
just recently found
um that basically uh provide lower
bounds on depth
of uh of uh of algorithms of quantum
algorithms
um by so so this particular
result by chia chang and lai uh
they defined an extension of simon's
problem
in a recursive way in which you cannot
actually find the value of the function
without asking the the oracle many times
coherently and and they showed a depth
lower bound but this can be massaged
to a lower bound also on the qualm
complexity
and this is another depth lower bound um
uh for the for the welded tree um
algorithm quantum algorithm so i i guess
my question would be a bit like do you
need coherence for quantum speed up
and simus seems to suggest no
so my question is like in that case what
what does give the advantage there
as compared to coherence
so coherence is not does is not
something that lies in
in empty space um here
coherence means coherence between i mean
this has
a context the context is that we're
talking here about an
a new type of exponential advantage of
quantum computation
because of the motivation it's it's a
new type because we're talking about
experiments and for experiments it's the
same
old um cohere
you know entanglement it's the same
quantum states that we all know
but the application is very different
it's uh
these are and the way you look at things
is different
so what this what we get here is an
exponential advantage for the
application of quantum experiments where
the setting is this
uh interaction between lab
register and work register etc but the
type of
you know the mathematics is the same you
have entanglement and you have uh
okay but the difference is that kind of
the oracle has a memo here right which
in simon's case it just doesn't have so
there's not much of a point in some
sense to talk about that there
right i mean it's essential for you
example that that at least one of the
things
you want to distinguish as a memory
right so it remembers the random unitary
right and this is what here the depth is
achieved not necessarily with the memory
with an extra memory
the depth lower bound but it does
require the coherence and time between
the different oracle applications
actually uh gary what would you would
you get uh
would you get such a separation from
every quantum communication complexity
speed up so if you have an exponential
speed up in quantum
communication complexity would it
automatically give you such an
advantage no no no no no because quantum
communication complexity
actually cannot give you um
um any advantage in qualm complexity
because you because um because the the
exponential separations are between
log and and n right the the the
once once you once you talk about the
size of the input
um um the
so so in communication complexity um
you can only hope to have separation
between
log the size of the input and the size
of the input
that's the exponential separation
but if you have an oracle count you get
more
okay we can take it off offline yeah yes
okay i looked at it a while back i
i don't have an answer right now but i
think not
um okay so look can i follow up on
mesh's question
maybe this is brief maybe there is a
class where you can
show you have a similar set of um
separations
which would be the quantum channel
discrimination problem
when you use entanglement versus no
entanglement because there
when you serialize the entangled query
of
the quantum channel and you want to
distinguish classes of quantum channels
so it's a decision problem again um
the the serialization would correspond
to your coherence
in time
let's take it offline it's uh let's
discuss this it's uh
i need to i need to think a little bit
about it
but let me just i forgot to mention here
the setting that we're talking here is
is is very close to a setting that huang
king and preschool uh also uh discussed
in the context of quantum machine
learning
and um they found um a quantum
exponential separation between coherent
and incoherent
different pro definition of a problem in
the context of this quantum machine
learning
but not in their case in their case the
the experiment the quantum experiment is
not efficient so it's just in query
complexity
but they also we're interested in in
very similar questions and the setting
is is very
similar um okay so so to wrap up the
just with the questions there basically
um
i think we are at the midst of a new era
of of quantum experiments and quantum
measurements
being slowly or maybe very fast
incorporating more and more ingredients
from quantum computation
into them and uh there there's there's
lots
of theory that is missing like we don't
have good algorithms and i'm sure that
that there are fancy quantum experiments
that can be done in which
uh maybe one can use sophisticated
states and
and highly adaptive i mean structured
adaptive experiments
um that is not are not being used now
so this is my first question and the
second question which i didn't get to
talk about
at all is this um all this gets
completely
um how do you say that
nothing is is correct when there's noise
the swap test for example between n
qubit states
when there's noise um with some
probability per qubit
um the swap test doesn't work uh there's
noise with some
constant probability the swap test for
for
both situations of of orthogonal or
similar states
so can we actually talk about um
such advantages uh in the qualm
complexity
setting even in the nisk era
okay so thanks
and i'm very happy for questions
thanks terry those it's very
interesting so uh questions uh is um
there there were two questions that uh
um we didn't get to during the talk um
so there's one from alec dharmas
um and is how how does the
qual model of experiments apply to
natural experiments
uh situations where the experimenter
cannot control the means of
interrogating
uh row n which you can only observe
gives examples of jumping up on scale
using gravitational lensing to try to
characterize bhs
sorry i need i need some explanation
about the question
yeah can you can you interpret the
question
i think the idea is about if you are
aren't able to control the interrogation
um then what happens in this call model
but i i mean the whole idea is that i
model
in the kwa model what is it that i'm
able to do and what is it that i'm not
so i have some control and
that is sort of put in this uh in this
part of the
of the of the picture
this is what i i do control and this is
what i don't control
and um and so if i don't control
anything then that's a problem
but uh but but for any such setting
there will be some
some complexity of the
of the problem it could be that that if
you don't have enough control you can't
do anything
alex did you want to ask more
uh yeah maybe verbally um just just uh
i get i guess in my my putative natural
experiments the
the the choice is really just to choose
the black hole
in terms of what what galaxies might
have happened to be behind
uh so so the the uh
i mean the notion of natural experiment
astronomers are stuck with this
uh this this approach uh
yet nonetheless they're they're obser
observing phenomena that that have
quantum aspects
uh so it's just a question about the
the boundaries of the qualm approach
yeah this is so basically you're saying
um
this gedan can experiment of preschool
and haydn hayden this is a it's very
nice but we you don't
this is too good duncan um you can't
actually interact with
uh with a black hole um so basically
it's just
observing some properties and
post-processing exactly right
you you you choose your black hole uh
and i don't know hope for hope for the
variation
uh in interaction that that's
appropriate if john is in the audience
maybe he can actually uh contribute here
more than me
um i don't know if he is um
but uh but i think that once once you
don't have
interaction then the the setting is less
interesting
you don't have there's no there's no
notion of entanglement between
the system and and your your
experimental device
yeah okay i'll buy that okay
oh can i ask you a question so
i'm trying to still set the
my mindset for this new setting so is it
different from having
a quantum computer that i have a full
access to
which is coupled to the environment
which has memory
so how is it different from that setting
like the
so i mean i'm just calling the
environment for your nature except that
now this environment has a memory so
like how is it different like
is it the same situation
well that was umesh's question from from
the beginning that
why don't i just uh refer to this as the
environment but the whole point is that
these hidden degrees of freedom are
degrees of freedom that we are
interested in
uh your interest is in the environment
therefore we don't call it environment
i see
i mean it you could you could some i
mean i don't know what you mean by
environment but sometimes you
could actually treat the environment as
a physical system and ask some question
about it
i say thank you thank you yeah but but i
think it's not not completely meaningful
to separate between row and between e
right because there's inequivalent
representations where you shift
complexity between the two of them
yeah i think the most radical
interpretation would be that you have a
fully programmable quantum processor in
the e
and then you encode the whole the whole
process in in in the whole for instance
then you can get any eu one from from
this row right so so you could have a
hardwired e
if you would have an infinite system
that you can shift quite a lot the
complexity between the two
right but you don't care about the
complexity of both
right i mean i guess it depends the same
is true for physical theories right i
could say
i do x-ray diffraction and my
description of my crystal is not a
crystal it's it's
full quantum theory and and then the
state is actually saying there are atoms
sitting in these positions right that's
probably not what you would usually do
but that's one option so i i think there
is also in the normal modeling of a
physical situation there's flexibility
what you assume is your state and what
is kind of the interaction
but probably one is more natural in a
different situation
it occurs to me that maybe what's
confusing umesh or what i got stuck with
in the
beginning is it could be alleviated by
thinking of l
not as the lab but rather maybe the
laser
so for me like n was an atom and l is a
laser
and so norbert's point um is a little
more difficult in this case because the
laser can only do certain things to the
to the atoms
and so anyway dorito i very much like
your framework and i think it can
describe
everything that i can think of in terms
of these kinds of experiments
okay but laser is a good uh that's a
good way to
to make an excuse for the l
um so would you would you agree with
that dory but wouldn't that limit your
experiments if it was just a laser no no
i i think that laser is
uh is a proxy for for basically
everything that allows an interaction
between me
and what i don't have access to um
so so i i
i was joking it's not really enough it's
it's basically
for example in the verification in the
verification
protocol what you need here for
l is to is to be able to contain your
uh your few qubits that allow you allow
allow you to interact with the physical
quantum computer
as well as some polynomially many
classical bits that basically provide
you with a description with the ability
to provide a description to the quantum
computer
so you need you need an elaborate uh you
need
sufficient freedom in this l so in
particular in in general you might even
have
n entangled qubits which are which are
part of this
interaction definitely yeah yeah
yeah and i was yeah but an
experimentalist would just call that a
laser still it's just a very
sophisticated laser
maybe a single atom laser which happens
to be controlled by a number of cupids
so its light from query to query can be
highly entangled with the previous
query yeah it's a question
it's a question maybe i mean i don't
know if it's possible to actually
reduce the whole framework to something
with only one
qubit here um for example that would
it it could actually need it could be
that that for the general
framework you actually need um
many qubits to interact at the same time
and you can spread
it over time i don't know that's good
but i would be happy to let you have
multiple lasers
yeah okay okay related question then
is it different from the following so
you have a quantum computer and you have
a system of interest
that undergoes its own quantum channel
and there's a coupling
type of coupling between the system and
your quantum computer
that you can turn on and off and there
are many different types of couplings
and you can turn each of them
individually on and off each time you do
so can you be modeling this way is it
the same
and the coupling is between a quantum
computer and and your physical system
and you just change the coupling
yeah and then the coupling has a
specific form could be time dependent
but the constraint is somewhat
well it depends on what constraint you
have because this quantum circuit in
general is a general quantum circuit so
if if the coupling can allow for general
interactions then
i do have a quantum computer so that's
the general quantum circuit
but some component of the quantum
computer is coupled to the system of
interest
with a specific coupling that i can only
turn on and off
i think the answer is yes right because
that's the area epsilon and
l
so if if is this specific coupling that
you can turn on and off
part of the of the thing that you're
trying to study
or is this what you're trying your probe
that you're trying to use in order to
measure
yeah between the two like between the
object we want to study
and the object that i have your access
to okay
so for me this is for me this is part of
your quantum circuit
and uh and it may not be sufficiently
expressive to actually just limit the
the the coupling in a very specific way
if the coupling is general then of
course it's like
it's like it's it's this model
um okay so
um you know um what do you say to
um to moving the rest of the discussion
to gather town i put
i put a link in there in the chat in the
q a
so please take a look and and uh
is that is that okay there it should be
yeah
let's do that okay okay great well
thanks again dory that was that was
fantastic
and uh let's go thank you
how do i move there uh there's a
there's a there's a link in the chat
right
you you should have you should have it
anyway but uh
uh i just posted the link in the chat
okay uh ashley posted it again so it's
the last
i see an entry in the chat okay thank
you
okay great see you all down bye bye
you